[Musique]
c'était ma vie quand c'était plus jeune
directrice générale d'un groupe
multinational américain
une carrière fulgurante
des diplômes d'excellence des meilleures
écoles de commerce et des médailles d'or
dans des compétitions sportives tout me
réussissait tout univers mois il avait
l'impression que personne et rien pour m
arrêter
évidemment ma confiance en moi semblait
indestructible
et là
je suis tombé du haut de ma tour en
quelques secondes
en 2008
comme un tsunami la crise économique et
financière
arrive depuis les états unis touche le
monde entier
la majorité des entreprises peut être
aussi la vôtre
et travaillons pour un groupe
international américain gelé pris en
pleine face
au lieu de construire ma marque ouvrir
des points de vente
embaucher des talents on me demande de
faire le contraire de
couper les budgets de fermer les
boutiques et de me séparer d'une grande
partie de mes équipes
et puis la direction de new york
décident de fusionner ma marque
avec une autre
étant la plus jeune directrice générale
dé 2 on me demande de partir
mais six marques
nous sommes obligés de nous séparer de
vous you're fired
quoi moi c'est pas possible
mais non
jamais
mais quelle chute
les américains de donner une heure pour
prendre un carton plié mais à faire
rendre mon ordinateur et de partir
en quelques minutes vous étiez tout est
aussi plus rien vous incarniez la
réussite est là vous incarnez les chics
le téléphone sonne et sans cesse elle a
plus personne qui t'appelle
vous étiez au fermement
non vous êtes
né en
il a une phrase de walt disney qui dit
parfois la meilleure chose qui puisse
vous arriver dans la vie c'est de
prendre un grand coup de pied dans le
visage
moi j'ai pris un grand coup de pied dans
mon visage mais j'ai trouvé pas que
c'était la meilleure chose qui puisse
m'arriver
au début quand je les prix
mais aujourd'hui je dirais qu'il avait
raison
pendant les premières semaines
après mon licenciement
j'étais comme immobilisée
je ne sortais plus je voulais plus voir
quelqu'un j'avais honte d'avoir perdu un
poste aussi prestigieux
des milliers de questions ce tour monté
dans ma tête je pense que
je n'ai jamais pleuré autant dans ma vie
et ma confiance en moi
était complètement par terre
et même pendant les prochaines semaines
je sentais que tout seul
je ne peux pas me relever
alors j'ose
tout doucement de prendre un téléphone
et d'appeler quelques amis proches
je leur raconte ce qui s'était passé
il me coûte il m'a vite même à la maison
et là je dis
tu n'es pas fini
d'un cran des amis
même si j'avais perdu beaucoup d'amis
parce que
j'étais beaucoup moins puissante même
plus puissantes du tout
et parfois j'entends dire mais michael a
pourquoi tu crées pas ton entreprise
maintenant avec toutes ces expériences
oui mais bon sur quoi avec qui comment
j'avais jamais écrit en business plan
dans ma vie ni j'étais obligé de
chercher du business sa venue vers moi
du coup je décide de changer ma
stratégie
et je commence à aller à la rencontre
des personnes dans mon réseau qui
pourrait m'inspirer qui avait déjà
réussi dans l'entrepreneuriat qui
pourrait peut-être m'apporter un tout
petit peu de confiance
des connaissances les anciens clients
les anciens professeurs
des entrepreneurs inspirant et comme ça
me fait beaucoup de bien je commence à
organiser un véritable marathon de
rencontres entre la france et
l'allemagne mon pays natal
est de plus en plus avec chaque
rencontre je commence
à combler mon puzzle il avait par
exemple eric qui avait déjà créé
beaucoup d'entreprises dans sa vie avec
succès qu'ils me montrent tous les
avantages d'être indépendante
puis il y avait dominique mon ancien
professeur en marketing
extrêmement bien connecté très généreux
il ne fait rencontrer plein de monde
et puis puis ils avaient tous via
mon camarade de classe de l'école
primaire
il était de passage à paris il est
devenu un grand dirigeant
dans une entreprise américaine
dans le digital
il cherche un consultant ou un chef de
projet qui pourrait pour dîner la
première mise en place du site
e-commerce pour lacoste waouh
il me dit micaela je te connais depuis
tout petit
je sais comment tu travailles je sais
aussi qu'elle poste eu à occuper pendant
ces dernières années
je te fais confiance
de mener ce projet avec succès
si tu veux
et même si tu connais pas grand chose en
e-commerce ce n'est pas grave ça
s'apprend et je vais te former
si tu veux
et là je réalise mais c'est énorme
opportunité qui est juste face à moi il
suffit de la saisir et je me dis mais
vas-y
c'est comme une lumière qui s'allume
dans tout encore comme une chaleur qui
montrent une joie une excitation sa
santé bout et là je me dis fons créé
enfants en entreprise de conseil ne les
exclut confirme à tobias et vas-y pause
le nom de ta boîte merck vision
alors pendant tout ce chemin
de rencontre
je me suis rendu compte que ce n'était
pas à travers des livres
ou à travers la méditation que je
pourrais me reconstruire
mais c'était grâce aux autres
grâce à la rencontre avec beaucoup de
personnes qui m'a porté
leur confiance
le plus difficile pendant ce chemin de
questionnements
d'apprentissage c'était deux choses tout
d'abord de savoir filtrer
les tas de conseils les tas d'astuces
bout est pas bon et de les comparer avec
mes propres convictions mes propres
envies mes propres valeurs
c'est de savoir identifier les bonnes
personnes qui avaient la capacité
de médée de me redonner de la vie
et de la confiance
c'est un petit peu comme si vous êtes
face à une énorme montagne très complexe
peut-être d'evariste que vous avez envie
de monter mais tout seul ce n'est pas
possible
donc il vous faut trouver des bons
guides qui vous accompagne en toute
sécurité tout en haut du sommet
et pendant ce chemin vous allez
rencontrer quatre types de personnes
quatre types de guide
alors tout un pas encore avant de monter
vous allez rencontrer des faux guides
j'ai envie de les appeler aussi des
nuisibles
pourquoi
ce sont des gens qui ne vous tire pas
vers le haut mais plutôt vers le bas si
ce sont des pessimistes par nature dans
l'opposition
ils voient des difficultés et des
problèmes partout
et dans cette même catégorie il ya aussi
des gens qui se frottent les mains
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas que vous
réussissez
il songea l'ont
eu c'est faux guides il faut les éviter
il faut les écarter il faut les fuir pas
ce qui vous freine
ensuite il ya un deuxième catégorie de
guide
ce sont des guides gentils
ils ont envie de vous aider mais peuvent
pas vous aider pourquoi parce qu'ils ne
connaissent pas le chemin en leur
présence vous vous sentez probablement
confortable parce qu'ils vous apprécient
mais le problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément le réseau qu'il vous faut
pendant cette situation est parfois
leurs conseils s'appliquent plus à eux
mêmes qu'à vous
ensuite nous avons un troisième type de
guide
des guides accorder des guides connectés
ils sont très importants parce que ils
ont exactement les réseaux qui vous faut
ils vont vous mettre en contact avec
plein de personnes vous ouvrir des
portes qui vous inspirent dans votre
réflexion ils sont indispensables
et ensuite nous avons un quatrième type
de guide
ils sont rares ils sont précieux mais il
existe ils ont la capacité de vous
accompagner tout en haut du sommet j'ai
envie de les appeler les sherpas ou des
guides miracle
et il vous accompagne en haut
ils vont le faire
si vous le voulez
un jour tôt ou tard vous serez parterre
étudiants entrepreneurs ou militaires
sachez que vous n'êtes pas seuls dans
l'univers
sans attendre
ni perdre de temps à les rencontrer le
plus de gens
qui vous aident à traverser le pont
vous guideront vers le rebond
le rebond
vers une autre vie
pouvoir dire pourquoi j'existe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]